flags wave in what israel says is a
celebration and palestinians call a
provocation
[Applause]
the israeli flag march part of what's
known by israelis as jerusalem day is a
holiday when israeli forces captured
east jerusalem in 1967 during the six
day war
for israel it's victory for the
palestinians its occupation
[Applause]
in recent years though ultra-nationalist
israeli groups have used the flag march
to push their own agenda
a minority openly racist far-right group
like lahava used the march to call for
the expulsion of all palestinians from
what was once historical palestine and
for the first time publicly called for
the dismantling of the third holiest
site in islam the dome of the rock in
the al-aqsa mosque compound
this year public security minister omar
baralev has allowed the march to travel
through damascus gate the heart of
occupied east jerusalem hamas which
rules the gaza strip is monitoring the
situation i think we as hamas we are not
hesitate to
use any means
in order to stop and to to deter the
extremists from doing this big mistakes
against our people and our palestinians
in the laksamoas or in jerusalem
we think that israel is doing now a
big catastrophe in this region
last year the march combined with the
forced expulsions of palestinians in the
sheikh gerard neighborhood sparked at
the 11 day war on gaza when hamas
threatened israel with rockets
mitchell barack an independent israeli
political consultant says allowing the
march to enter palestinian areas is once
again dangerous
for israelis to fly the flag anywhere in
israel in jerusalem or east jerusalem it
makes a statement israeli sovereignty is
demonstrated there by the israeli army
the israeli police that is there and is
deciding who can march where can they
march what flag can be flown by which
people and that's going to be a boiling
point in areas outside of the old city
palestinians clashed with israeli police
[Applause]
[Music]
clashes also took place across the
occupied west bank where the israeli
army used live fire and tear gas against
unknown palestinians
well it seems that the marchers have
actually dictated to the israeli police
how they're going to come in to damask
escape they've opened up another route
this was never supposed to happen there
are only a few israeli police here
despite a huge operation security
operation across the city and the
israeli police are simply overwhelmed
the marchers openly chanting hate
slogans and proclaiming that this is a
jewish only land this young generation
they're out in force believe that
completely and these people are the ones
that are backing the israeli government
and keeping it in power and as long as
that's the case they have very loud
voice at the heart of the israeli
government imran khan al jazeera
occupied east jerusalem